Okay, so welcome to lecture number 14 of
the course.
And let's start with a very short
summary of where we are, right? So
again, the task is the same as before.
So we have the PDE, which is given in
this abstract form.
And underlying the PDE or
along with the PDE, there is a solution
operator
uh script G, calligraphic G, which maps
functions to functions. So it takes in
the inputs. Here, it could be the
coefficients A, the source terms F, and
it turns out the solution here. So this
is the setup that we are in.
And since we are dealing with mappings
between function spaces, uh as we have
seen before,
we have to be careful.
In particular, what we have to do is to
ensure this principle of continuous
discrete equivalence
that I've been droning on about for
long.
And we do that through this
representation equivalent neural
operator. So the idea is very simple,
that instead of looking at mappings
between function spaces, we do an exact
correspondence or an exact equivalence
by going through discrete spaces, for
instance, functions on a grid. So you
start with the continuous function
space, you go down to the discrete space
like this.
You
operate here,
and then you go up back through some
reconstruction operator, right? And this
diagram should commute. So this is the
basic principle.
And we are still in the search of what
can be an effective Reno. So in the last
lectures, we saw that CNNs are not
because even the convolution operation
is not preserving the structure.
Nor are FNOs, even though the
convolution operation preserves, the
nonlinearities don't preserve the
structure. So neither of them are
Renos.
We did see some examples, for instance,
the spectral neural operator and
DeepONet, but these have they perform
rather poorly. So we still the
objective, as I said in the last
lecture,
is to find a structure-preserving
continuous discrete equivalent map, you
know, that actually works. And
hopefully, we will do that today. Of
course, there are always issues with
everything that one constructs.
Okay, so this is the setup. We're trying
to find something which takes as inputs
functions, which turns as outputs
functions, and it does it in the
structure-preserving manner, which is
illustrated here through the diagram
here.
Okay.
So, let's do that. And to do so, what
we're going to do is to essentially
bring back convolutions. If you
remember,
both CNNs and FNO, they were doing
convolutions, right? So, the essential
mode of operation was always
convolution.
So, CNN did it in physical space and FNO
in Fourier space, if you recall
correctly. And then,
sorry about this. I don't know why this
came
why it went back.
Okay. So, here we are. So, there is
convolution, and it's always followed by
nonlinearity. So, convolution,
nonlinearity.
And what we're going to do is to see if
convolutions can really be because
both FNO as well as Deep O Net, they did
not use this convolution, right? They
don't They sort of broke the structure
of space, which is what I was trying to
allude to in the last lecture. They
broke the structure of space. Somehow,
we have to bring that back, the
relationality between spatial elements.
So, can convolutions be brought back
into the reckoning?
And why is that?
So, before the rise of vision
transformers and diffusion models,
convolutions were essentially the main
models in vision. So, if you consider
image processing, classification,
generation, and so on,
convolutions play even today a very,
very big role in it. Right? So, this is
one point about convolutions. Second,
particularly when you do them in
physical space, there is a concept of
locality. In other words, if you think
in terms of uh image or a
one-dimensional
function, then what convolutions do is
that nearby points, they are taken
together.
So, that neighborhood relations,
locality is somehow constrained. And of
course, there is uh computational
efficiency in convolutions because
essentially what you can think is if you
think of in terms of uh matrix vector
multiply,
then convolutions, this matrix is going
to be sparse, right? Extremely sparse
because it has this localization
structure.
So, convolutions are computationally
efficient. And also, one can realize
that there are some links between
convolutions, CNNs,
and finite difference methods. Now,
finite difference methods are a very
popular way to solve PDEs. And it turns
out that you can rewrite finite
difference methods in terms of
convolutional kernels. I won't do it
here. This has been done sometime back.
So, there is an intrinsic link between
these methods.
So, given these considerations, it sort
of makes sense that we bring back
convolutions into the reckoning, right?
We we somehow bring them in.
There is of course a big issue. If you
remember even in our last um
lectures, two lectures, we know that
they are not reynolds. CNNs are not
reynolds. They are There is some
inconsistency in function space.
And somehow we have to work with and we
have to remove this inconsistency to be
able to solve this problem in some
sense, okay? How do we do that? So, this
will be the main focus of my lecture
today.
Let me start by
essentially saying convolutions strike
back.
So, I'm going to describe in the next uh
half an hour, 40 minutes, this
architecture which was proposed last
year
by essentially my lab. And this is
called convolutional neural operators.
And you'll see that it has many of these
desirable properties that we aspired
for. So, in in particular, it keeps
convolution, so it has all these nice
properties, locality, computational
efficiency, and so on and so forth.
In addition, it's also a Reno or we are
going to construct it in such a manner
that it is going to be a Reno. But
remember that the reason why we failed
last time is because convolution itself
So, remember that we always have this um
let's say workflow, right? So, we have
convolution, we have non-linearity.
So, what we have to do is to modulate
these two. So, remember that for CNNs,
convolution itself was no longer
structure preserving, and for FNO, even
though convolution was structure
preserving, the non-linearity was not.
So, we have to work with both these
layers or both these objects in order to
ensure that the right kind of structure
that we want is going to be preserved.
And that is what is done in CNO, for
instance. So, the idea is then I I'm
describe it in quite some detail, but
here is sort of a graphic.
And again, the point is that we always
have um convolutions and
non-linearities. There are many other
operations that I'm going to describe uh
in some detail.
So, the picture, as you can see, is that
there are many, many layers. As always,
these are sort of layered. There are
There is a compositional structure to
them. And what we are going to do is to
see how convolutions or convolutions
play a role here. This K is
convolutions.
And the non-linearities are going to be
given by this sigma.
But there are some additional elements
to it that I'm going to describe
during the lecture. Okay? So, let us
start with where we stand.
So, remember that with Reno's, the point
is that you have to work with the right
kind of function spaces. So, the
function spaces cannot be too big,
otherwise we'll not be able to retain
the structure.
So, the function spaces, this is of
course a special case, but it's a very
illustrative special case. So, what
we're going to do is that we are going
to build an operator, let me call it as
G or G star. I don't remember how did I
call this.
G star.
This is operator that is going to take
functions to functions. And these
functions are going to be band-limited
functions.
So, remember that I defined band-limited
functions. So, essentially what you do
is you take a function, you take its
Fourier transform, and you cut off the
high frequencies beyond a certain point.
So, essentially for BW, this is all the
functions. So, you had you belongs to BW
implies that the Fourier transform
is the support of the Fourier transform.
I should have used that.
The support of the Fourier transform
of you is contained inside minus WW.
Just for simplicity. It could be a
vector space or a multi-dimensional
space, of course. So, we are taking
band-limited functions. This allows us
to work with this continuous discrete
equivalence because for band-limited
functions, remember that we can
essentially the discrete version of it
is
essentially point values on a grid.
Point values on a grid. So, in other
words, if you go back to the diagram,
and this diagram is very important,
that's why I keep on repeating. So, if
you have band-limited functions here, so
let me use another color. BW or perhaps,
then this is just functions on a grid.
So, little L2 functions on a grid. So,
there is a clear correspondence between
the two as long as this Nyquist
conditions are satisfied. And Nyquist
conditions say that the grid spacing is
essentially less than one over two times
the frequency, right? That's that's the
basic the basic idea behind these
functions. So, we are always going to
operate between band-limited functions.
And my input here, you,
Okay, sorry for the notational
confusion here, but okay, does not
matter.
So, my input is given as a band-limited
function, and my output is also going to
be a band-limited function. And in
between, I'm going to process it through
different steps, through different
layers, and through different objects,
right?
And so, what are the building blocks?
The obvious ones, which are similar to
that of
FNO, are these lifting and projection
operators. So, remember, the first thing
that we do is that let's imagine that we
are
looking at the state of the weather.
The state of the weather outside is
given by several variables,
essentially temperature, pressure,
velocities, things like that. So, there
are fixed number of So, this input here
So, let's say that my U, which is the
input, is some function. Let's say that
this is a band-limited function, which
maps the domain D, the domain that we
are in,
to some vector space. So, this is to R
R
M, let's say.
Okay, so this is the sort of And D is
some domain inside RD.
So, this is
So, there are M-dimensional inputs,
okay? Think of density, pressure,
temperature, velocities, and so on. So,
the first thing that we always do is
that these are sort of the physical
features. There is no reason why this is
the right kind of representation of the
system in machine learning for a
learning algorithm to work. So, what one
does is either to embed it So,
typically, what you do is that you embed
it into a high-dimensional feature
space, okay? So, this is precisely this
operator that it takes U.
So, PU belongs to some R
DN, okay? So, DN is some
high-dimensional feature space. DN is
much greater than M.
We already saw that in FNO. So, So, can
think of it as adding channels or
channel augmentation.
So, this is the first step that you take
your input, which has M features, and
you embed it into a much bigger space,
which is
let's say D in.
Let's say four features, you go to 20
features, or 100 features, or something
like that. So, that provides some
effective coordinate system where the
learning algorithm can function better.
So, this is needless to say almost in
every algorithm, this is this is fairly
standard, okay? So, this is the lifting
operator. Then you work with this V0.
This is the sort of the lifted version.
So, this has more channels than much
more channels than your original signal,
right? Then you do your processing. This
is These are the steps, the processing
steps, and then you end up with some
output after X number of layers, usually
eight to 10 layers, and then you have to
come back to your density, your
pressure, your velocity, the number of
channels that you have, and this is
typically you're back to your
RM, right? So, this is the thing back,
the projection back. So, you take all
these channels, and you shrink them
back. Now, P and Q, this can be simple
linear maps, that's the easiest way,
tensors essentially, or you can take
them to be MLPs, means in general MLPs.
But at least in the implementations that
we have, these are mostly linear maps,
okay? So, P and Q, these are linear
maps, they don't do anything
fancy, they don't work with space at
all. So, they don't change space, so all
that they do is they add channels, or
take out channels. So, these are by
definition reno's, means they don't
affect the structure of space, so there
is nothing nothing fancy happening
there. So, is that clear? So, this is a
part of every This is a part of every
package that
you you sort of associate a new
coordinate system that is better able to
learn features in the data, okay? This
is This is sort of standard.
So, now what we have to operate is given
these two operators, we have to work
with the two essential ones.
Uh give me 1 second.
You know what? I have actually forgotten
to start the recording.
Okay, I have to somehow patch this.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sorry about that. People miss half an
hour.
Okay, coming back to
I will I will patch it up later. So,
essentially what you do is that
you do this projections and this lifting
and this projection back, right? So,
what is left then is that you have
to work with convolutions and
nonlinearities.
Do you have a question? I can
No?
Yes, I will I will just just hold hold
your patience a little because I will
talk about them, right?
10 is just a number that I threw out. It
could be three, it could be six, it
could be 12. I think the biggest models
that we have probably have 16 layers.
So, it's sort of
It depends a little bit on the data that
you have, it depends a little bit on the
computer that you have and so on.
Okay, so now let us look at the key
building blocks because this lifting and
projection they generally come with uh
with the basic structure. So, the key
building block is of course the first
key building block is convolution.
So, this is convolution
in physical space. Okay, this is the
difference from FNO
because we are going to do everything in
physical space now, which is good
because it keeps some locality, it
doesn't matter what boundary conditions
you take and so on and so forth.
And what is the contrast now? So,
remember that contrast is always with
the CNN because the CNN remember that
this was the structure of the CNN. In
the CNN, we had everything working at a
discrete level, and as a consequence, we
failed to have this structure-preserving
property.
But, let me now try to explain how the
convolutions work.
And this requires a little bit of time.
So, what we do is that we have
continuous convolutions.
So, of course, everything is continuous.
We have continuous convolutions, but of
course, on the space of band-limited
functions. So, in other words, the you
have to do a convolution, so you have F,
which belongs to band-limited functions.
You have a convolution kernel.
So, this is as before. So, you have a
convolution kernel KW.
And then, you have to do a convolution.
So, KW star
F is nothing but the integral over D
of KW X minus Y F of Y
DY, which could be the same as
KW Y
F of X minus Y DY.
So, this is in the function space,
right? But, we have to do something at
the discrete level. So, what we do, and
this is the key trick here. There are
two key tricks. The first is that our
convolution kernel itself is actually
discrete. Okay? What does that mean?
That means that this KW function, KW
of Z, for instance,
is nothing but
a sum of some KJ
delta. I'm just talking in 1D, but this
is
2D, 3D, 4D, whatever. The generalization
is obvious.
ZJ.
Okay? So, what you do is that you still
keep the kernel discrete. In other
words, so this is the Dirac. Okay? All
of you should know this notation. This
is the Dirac delta function.
So, in other words, if you have a
picture,
you pick some points. These are
generally points on a grid because
remember that we had band-limited
functions. So, we we have points on a
uniform grid.
And then, essentially, what you do is
that you have different values at these
points. Some K2, some K1.
Uh K4, K3, K4, something like this. You
fix the size of the kernel. The size of
the kernel is fixed a priori.
And these are discrete points. So, what
does that mean? So, if you now evaluate
this integral here, uh follow. So, this
is uh discrete. So, this will simply
mean that this is a summation over J.
Uh KJ
of f of x minus uh ZJ. Right? So, this
is what it is. So, what you're doing now
is that you're fixing the discrete
kernel
as before, as in a convolutional neural
network, but you're acting it in a
continuous manner. Okay? So, this is
sort of the first key point that we are
And we are with band-limited functions.
So, we're always having a clear
correspondence, a clear sort of
mirroring between the continuous and the
discrete. But, why is this a reno?
Means, how do we apply it on different
grids and so on? So, first of all, I
will explain it in two stages. So, in
terms of the commutative diagram, this
is fairly straightforward, because you
take band-limited functions, and it is
straightforward to compute, it is
straightforward to calculate, that once
you take this discrete kernel, then this
mapping that I defined here is going to
map to band-limited functions. It's It's
a one-line argument. Um you can check it
in the paper, for instance. But, at the
discrete level, what happens is that
band-limited functions are related here
by the sinc filters. So, the remember
that this size here
are given by sinc functions.
Or, you can think of a band-limited
function f of x as the summation of f of
xj
sinc of x minus xj, roughly speaking,
right? So, this is the this is the basis
interpretation that we have and because
there is this clear correspondence
between point values, it is a little
argument to show that even this entire
diagram, so you can come here, you can
work here, you can go like this or the
other way around, it does not really
matter. It is the same It is the same
problem that is being done.
But okay, so this this structure, this
algebraic structure is very very clear,
but how does it contrast with CNNs?
Means what is the difference that we did
with CNN that changes things, okay? And
this is best explained So remember that
we have this discrete kernel, okay? And
we are going to keep this kernel fixed.
We're not going to resize the kernel as
some of you suggested. What we are going
to do is to resize the functions, okay?
So the inputs. So here, remember that
this was the issue with the with the
CNNs. Let me revisit this. So what we
did was that I took my kernel, the
similar to what we have before. I took
my kernel,
I took my signal, so I took the let's
say on a coarse grid. I took these
values, multiplied them, and I got some
answer. And then I took a different
values
because now you're on a finer grid. I
multiplied them and of course I got a
different answer because I was not
changing the kernel, nor was I changing
the input signal. So now the difference
here is because we are working with this
band limited functions and because
there's a clear correspondence between
the continuous and the discrete, this is
how you do the convolution operation. So
let us say, so this is this is as
before, so okay? So this value is as
before. Now when we work with the with
this
let's say new signal, what you do is
because you have a correspondence
between the continuous and the discrete,
which is exact if the Nyquist barrier is
satisfied, so what you will do is that
you will take this function you will
take this point values. Remember that
you take these point values. You go
you're going to lift them up here to the
continuous level.
You're going to pull it down to the
discrete, right? Because then by the
sync filter, you can pull it down to the
discrete. And then you apply the
discrete kernel again.
Okay? And because these two functions
are identical, what happens is that by
re-interpolating like this, you are
going to essentially do this operation
here.
That first, you start with your discrete
inputs, pull them to the continuous
function space,
then resample them to the new or the
course grid, which was the original grid
where the kernel is defined, apply the
kernel,
push it up again to the continuous case,
and then go back. Okay? So, this is the
reason why the by working with these
discrete kernels, and while by at the
same time keeping the convolution kernel
fixed, but resizing your input functions
back into the size of the convolution
kernel, you are able to enforce that the
signal property is satisfied. Okay? So,
it's a somehow the fix was in the
understanding of the problem itself.
Because we understood that the problem
was that you were working with different
function spaces, different grids, and
you're using the same kernel. Now, all
that you do is to resize back to the
same grid. You can do that because you
have this
band-limited functions.
And then when you do that, you can see
that you can apply the same grid just by
re-interpolating, you
you get back the original function. So,
is that point clear? So, in other words,
this evaluation is not done directly, it
is done like this. So, of course,
obviously this uh signal property is
going to be satisfied. So, convolutions
are done in this particular manner, and
these are sort of the key points. Oh,
sorry.
I'm very allergic, so it's sort of
it's not a cold.
Okay, so this is the key point behind
the convolutional layers, that you have
this sort of
a resizing of the input rather than the
resizing of the convolution kernel.
Okay?
The kernel is always going to be fixed.
Or this is one way, of course, the way
in which we implement. Perhaps there are
other ways where this can be done.
Okay, that's so much about the contrast
with the CNNs, how we change, and how
this is kept
structure preserving.
Now, what about nonlinearities? Because
remember there's always convolutions and
nonlinearities. So now we fixed
convolutions, but you can say, "Okay,
what's the big deal?" Because in FNO,
convolution was already fixed, right? So
there's nothing nothing new that is
happening.
So, but the new is also at the level of
the nonlinearity, and this is where
interesting things happen. So let me
give you a quick recall. So if you
remember for
FNO, so this is quick recall. Now I
really need to you guys need to really
focus.
So if you recall,
sigma, this is your application of the
nonlinearity,
was the mapping you take an F, right? So
you take a function, you apply the
nonlinearity on the function, evaluate
it at a point X. This was nothing but
sigma, your usual nonlinearity,
applied on f of x. So this is how you
did it in FNO. So you took a function
and you just applied point-wise
ReLU for instance, or some other
activation function. And remember that
this was the problem then.
The problem was here, so the orange here
is the signal, the the function that is
there,
and then you apply nonlinearity. Let's
focus on ReLU. Smoother nonlinearities
don't make a big difference, but you
take ReLU,
and then you get the function in blue.
So all the negative parts are copped
out, right? So this is the action of
ReLU.
But when you look at it in Fourier
space, remember
that we are between band-limited spaces.
So, if you go between So, what happens
now is that the original function, the
function in orange, it was between -20
and 20 in frequency. Okay? It was capped
because this we just took band-limited
functions. As soon as you took ReLU,
what happens is that ReLU is a
non-linearity. Just imagine if you have
the square, the anything between -20 and
20 sin 20x squared becomes roughly sin
40x, right? So, you introduce higher
frequencies. Of course, what happens is
that the coefficients of these higher
frequencies could be small because the
function has some decay properties, but
you still see that there is some leakage
outside. So, for instance, if you take
40 for instance here, you can see that
there are non-zero frequencies.
Even at 60, there are non-zero
frequencies. So, what happens is that
non-linearity breaks the band limits.
So, all this nice uh picture that this
leads to aliasing because this
continuous-discrete equivalence is going
to be broken in this particular case.
Instead, so what are we going to do? How
do we solve this problem now?
So, the solution of the problem is in
identifying the problem itself, just
like we did with convolutions.
So, here is the idea. It's a very simple
idea.
What if at the application of the
non-linearity, instead of working with
the point-wise non-linearity, we do the
following? Okay? So, remember, so this
was my Nyquist barrier. This is the
Nyquist frequency, outside which, as you
can see, that there is uh leakage,
right? So, what if during the
application of the non-linearity, I
allow my frequencies to grow in some
manner? I allow my functions to have
higher frequencies.
In particular, let's uh use the double
the cutoff. Let's go to 40. Right? If
you go to 40, you can see that the
frequencies beyond 40 is still not
capped because they do you know it's
infinite the response is going to be
infinite but if it were it would have
been a square this would have been
between minus 40 and 40. But now the
higher frequencies the leakage here is
much smaller
compared to the original leakage that
was here right so you would expect that
the effect of aliasing would be reduced
okay so the idea is to somehow
accommodate this feature of
non-linearity. What do non-linearities
do? They take a signal with 3K
frequencies and they increase the
frequencies.
So then when we apply it we know that
the frequencies are going to increase
then of course the nice structures that
we have a loss that are aliasing errors.
So what if we do the following that we
start with a function
allow it to have higher frequencies
artificially potentially apply the
non-linearity with these high
frequencies and then bring back to your
original frequencies by using a low pass
filter typically right? So this kind of
an arrangement will imply that we will
leverage the fact that new frequencies
are created by sort of stemming it in
the beginning. We say okay fine new
frequencies are created so what because
I allow for that. Okay so this is
roughly the intuition behind it and the
idea that and to carry this out this is
this these kind of ideas were around in
the world of vision but we brought them
with this sort of
context at least we provided this kind
of context and this clear mathematical
understanding of these ideas. So what we
are going to do is that we are going to
apply two key operators which are going
to be new sort of objects that you have
probably not seen before in this context
and this will be what I call upsampling
and downsampling operators. So
upsampling is allowing for the creation
of these new frequencies then you apply
the non-linearity and downsampling is
coming back to your original frequencies
because remember at the end of the day
I am always working between these
band-limited functions.
So, I have to somehow come back to my
original band. But, while doing so, I'm
introducing these new frequencies.
And these new frequencies are through
this up-sampling and down-sampling
operators. So, before I write down the
expressions, let me try to explain what
it is. Perhaps, I can use a figure,
maybe this one.
Okay, so this is the non-linearity. This
is the non-linear activation module.
Activation module.
of signal.
Okay, so what do What does it do? And
please try to focus. So, you are given
your input, you do the convolutions.
Convolutions keep the band. This is what
I have kept on saying. So, you do a
convolution, and then you apply this
activation module, which is capital
sigma, right? So, what you do is your
signal, your input to this layer, to
this band, to this module is here.
So, this is a function with
just for illustration here, we have
taken 10 frequencies, or eight, or
something like that. So, these are given
by these points, or four frequencies,
and they're evaluated at eight points.
So, what up-sampling is going to do is
to increase the number of frequencies.
If you increase the number of
frequencies, you can evaluate at more
points while still keeping the same
structure, right? So, trivially, if you
you have access to a continuous
function, it simply means evaluating
this continuous function at more points,
right? So, this is These are the new
points as you can introduce. You're
introducing a new grid here.
Okay, depending on which band you want
to go to. So, this is done by saying
that you want to double the band, but
that may not be the case. You can
increase it by factor of four, by a
factor of eight, depending on the
non-linearity that you have, depending
on the problem that you have.
So, you have this additional
introduction uh, of frequencies. They in
a in the continuous case you do nothing
because your function is anyway defined
at all these points. But in the discrete
case, you have to do some sort of an
interpolation, okay? And then you apply
the non-linearity. This will be
pointwise, okay? So, the upsampling is a
non-local operation because you're
introducing new frequencies, and this is
not done in physical space, it is done
in Fourier space. So, this is, um, new
frequencies non-local. This is still
local. You can apply ReLU, GeLU,
whatever non-linearity switch, whatever
non-linearity that you have here, right?
Nothing, nothing strange here. But now
you have allowed for these high
frequencies, right? So, this means that
even if high frequencies are created,
they remain within the same band.
Ideally. Then you have to come back to
your original function, and this is
again the sinc interpolation because now
you you have these functions which are
defined on this new grid, roughly
speaking. And then you come back to the
original grid, so you take the
functions, you take the sinc
interpolant, and project it back. So,
this is your downsampling, okay? And
this is a way in which you can go from a
band-limited space to the same
band-limited space while artificially
growing frequencies and then quenching
them later, okay? So, this is roughly
the intuition that goes in. Of course,
you can, to realize it, you need some
formulas, and these are probably given
here.
So, as I said, at the continuous level,
upsampling is nothing because you are
just evaluating a function at new
points. So, these are the
This is your original band, but this is
your new band, okay? This could be
double.
In practice, actually, we say it to be
double, but you'll see that there is a
subtle point about whether it should be
double or four times or eight times and
so on and so forth.
So, this is straightforward. In discrete
terms, you have to do this with some
interpolation.
And this is interpolation with sinc.
I think you saw that in the in the
tutorial on CNO. And down sampling is
again an interpolation procedure because
you have to go to the sync functions and
then you project them back to the
original points and this is again done
through this
Sorry.
Again done through this uh formula here.
Okay?
But the the detail is not important.
What is important is the intuition here.
So, at all times we have this up
sampling and this down sampling
operations and these two things are very
very important because they they have to
work in tandem. Now, it turns out that
for instance, if my non-linearity was a
square, okay? If my non-linearity was a
square, I know exactly that as long as
this omega bar is greater than or equal
to two
omega or w bar is greater than or equal
to two w, then this entire process is
completely arena. Why? This is for a
square non-linearity. I'm going to
illustrate it for the non-linearities in
a bit.
Because what do you do here?
You go from w to two w. This is
and this is done by this up sampling and
this is precisely this sort of lifting
operation in some sense or raising it to
a higher frequency which is trivial in
some sense because of course these
functions function with 20 frequencies
is contained inside functions with 40
frequencies. There's nothing nothing to
be done here. Then you apply the
non-linearity. So, now remember that
since it is 20 frequencies, when you go
to take a square, it will have 40
frequencies. So, this is of course well
contained here. This mapping is between
w prime b w prime to b w prime and then
from 40 frequencies you can always come
back to 20 frequencies by using this
interpolation. And this is precisely the
discrete version of these nice operators
which is what I just described. So, of
course this entire thing commutes and
this is why this particular realization
is
is arena. Now, just imagine that instead
of applying the quadratic, the
non-linearity was not quadratic, but the
power fourth. Then, of course, this W
prime would be four times W, right?
Similarly, if it was power six, it would
be six times W. So, if you take any
polynomial essentially, then you can
compute the based on the highest degree
of the polynomial what this W prime
could be.
So, for polynomials, this is exact. This
construction is going to be exact. Of
course, it is going to be expensive
because to go to you have to go have
four times more grid points, six times
more grid points, eight times more grid
points, and so on. So, you pay a cost.
It's not for free.
However,
if you take rational functions, so
polynomials, this is exact, right? If
you take rational functions, if your
sigma of X is some polynomial divided by
another polynomial,
you can still do this because you have
polynomials, so you can solve a
non-linear equation by Newton. You have
polynomials on the left, polynomials on
the right, and you can still do it
exactly for rational functions. But, if
you take things like ReLU
and Swish, Swish for instance can be
approximated by a by quadratic
polynomial, then, of course, what
happens in that particular case is that
if this W prime W bar goes to infinity,
of course, everything can be
approximated by polynomials and you can
you can do this. But, in practice, you
cannot go to infinity, right? You have
to fix a bound.
So, you will have some error, but as you
can imagine, this error will be smaller
than it would have been if you did not
do this upsampling because if you did
not do this upsampling,
then these high frequencies would have
corrupted your signal, right? But, by
doing this upsampling, even with double,
then you sort of quench these high
frequencies and you're left with low
frequencies. So, this is not exact. It's
an approximation, but in practice, we
saw that nothing changes if you just
take two. You see? So, the frequencies
are high enough, or the the coefficients
of the frequencies are low enough. As a
consequence you don't really need to
process beyond
twice the number of frequencies. But in
principle you can do it for any order.
Okay? If you have polynomial or rational
non-linearities. But if you don't you
have to you have to make some
approximations. But you have to reduce
the aliasing error. And you'll see that
in in the numerical experiments in the
next part of the talk this is going to
be clear. So this is how you going to
sort of do the convolutions and you're
going to do the non-linearities. And you
have to put them together. Okay? So as
you can see in this very simple
structure I start with a signal. I raise
it by using the by augmenting the number
of channels, do a convolution, then
apply the non-linearity and then again
you can see convolution non-linearity
convolution non-linearity
till I end up with some stop and then
you go back to your original functions.
Okay? But so this is the plain vanilla
architecture that you can use. But as
you'll see I'll take a break now and
let's meet at 10:00 past. You'll see
after the break that in order to have a
practical architecture that works this
basic building blocks are not enough.
This basic building blocks of
convolution and non-linearities with
this up sampling and down sampling are
not enough. We have to put them together
in a more intricate manner in order to
sort of have some proper processing of
the signal. But this is after the break
and let's meet at 10:00 past. Okay? So
and see how this is done in practice.
This is in principle. I've given you all
the bases in principle and now we have
to take it and look for a practical
architecture. But that's after the
break.
Okay. So let's restart. So as I said
before the break
what we need to do is to put together
these ingredients that we have
convolution and nonlinearity.
And uh we do that in a very
sophisticated manner because we know
from computer vision because these ideas
of using convolutions and nonlinearities
come from computer vision that this has
to be done in a much more intricate
manner. You can't just stick a
convolution next to a nonlinearity, put
them in layers and get the results that
you want.
Okay, so here is how it is in practice.
That's why it's it's more complicated,
right? So as you can see that this has
this sort of a U-Net type architecture.
This is what works
from
long experience in computer vision. So
the idea is that you have to do
multi-scale processing of your signal.
So in other words, if you have an image
or any signal for that matter, it has
structures at many scales, right? Even
if it's a band-limited function, a
band-limited function might have
structures non-zero structures at 30
frequencies or 40 frequencies or 50
frequencies depending on the problem
that you have. So in that case, what you
have to do is from computer vision,
people have realized that you should
process these frequencies somehow
separately. So in some cases, you
process the high frequencies, some
cases, you process the low frequencies,
and you put all of them together.
And this is done in this sort of a U-Net
kind of an architecture, and let me try
to explain. So the building blocks are
exactly the same: up sampling, down
sampling, nonlinearities, convolutions.
It's exactly the same kind of a
structure as before, right?
So what you do is the following. Let me
first give you the heuristics, and then
we can look at the
details in a second. So you have a
signal which is of course on multiple
scales usually. And then what you do is
some sort of a scale separation, and
then
processing at different scales, and then
mix them up. Okay?
So of course, this is your signal. It is
four channels for instance. The first
thing that you do is through the
lifting, you add more channels. Okay?
So, that is you provide better
coordinates for the learning system so
that it can learn better. So, this goes
This goes without saying.
Then, the There are different kinds of
There are different kinds of layers
here. So, as you can see that they have
some names. Let me even expand it
further so that that you understand it.
So, the first layer here is what is
called an invariant block.
Okay? So, this is as you can see this is
a dark red color.
I can't see it at this resolution, but I
think you guys see what it is, right?
And what does it do? It takes a signal
um band-limited function. It puts a
convolution and it puts a nonlinearity.
And the nonlinearity itself, the
activation, has this upsampling and
downsampling layers, right? So, this is
what we have constructed. And when you
stick these two convolution and
nonlinearity, convolution is a Reno,
nonlinearity is a Reno.
When you add them together, of course,
when you compose them, you still get a
Reno. So, this is the first thing that
you do. So, you take the input and then
you just apply this convolution and
nonlinearity. This is what you would
expect and you would think that I just
stack these together and then I get my
architecture. No, we have to do a little
bit clever stacking.
And this is done in this layer. It is
called roughly an encoder. Okay? So,
this part is what is called an encoder.
And this part here is what is called a
decoder.
So, what the encoder does is that There
are two things it does. First, it takes
a signal and it keeps on, let's say,
downsampling it. So, it sort of
applies keeps on applying low-pass
filters, keeps on applying low-pass
filters. But at the same time, so it
also adds more and more channels. So,
essentially, this
visually, just to represent the cartoon,
the height of these boxes is your
resolution. Okay? So, the height of
these boxes is your resolution and the
width of these boxes is the number of
channels. So, in the beginning, you have
been given some resolution. I don't
know, 128 squared, and then you you just
add more channels, right? And then here,
you keep the same resolution, keep the
same number of channels, do some
processing. But now, you do some
processing by reducing the resolution.
Let's say you go from 128 squared to 64
squared. That's why you do this with
this downsampling operation, right? So,
this is what is called a D block, this
one here. This is a downsampling
operation, but you increase the number
of channels, okay? So, you add more
features, but you reduce you just
process some scales in the signal,
right? And this is what is done here.
So, this is this downsampling block.
So, you take the function, you do a
convolution, you do a non-linearity, and
you do a downsampling. So, you reduce
the resolution.
This is okay, means you're just reducing
the resolution, you are keeping the same
band limits, so it is still a reno, but
what you do is that you increase the
number of channels, okay? And you keep
on doing it. So, you take 128 squared,
in the next one you go to 64 squared,
then you go to 32 squared, 16 squared, 8
squared, and so on. Somewhere you have
to stop, of course. And this is what is
called the bottleneck.
Or
this is called the bottleneck.
So, the idea is that you at different
resolutions, you're processing different
features, which is very clear from
vision, right? Because what do we do in
vision? There are if you look at my
face, there are some gross features, for
instance, the outline of the face, the
outline of the hair, and so on. And
there are some sharp features, then the
exact location of the nose, the exact
location of the eyes, and so on. All
that it says is that different parts of
your network are processing different
inputs, okay? Some are focusing on the
broad features, some are focusing on the
sharp features, and we think of
functions, mathematical functions, in
the same manner. High frequencies, low
frequencies, different places I am
processing different things, okay? So,
this is this down D block, okay? It
consists of convolution, non-linearity,
and downsampling. The downsampling you
have already seen before what it is,
right? This is this interpolation with a
low-pass filter, and you go in this
manner as you can see I took a high
frequency signal then and here I'm just
processing some parts of the frequency,
here I'm processing even lower parts of
the frequency. So this is the decoder
part of it, which is very standard in
this unit architectures.
But now you process and you have to
build it up again, right? So you have to
you have to get back to your 128 squared
encoder, sorry I should have said. So
this is done by the decoder. So you have
to you have to now take the low
frequencies, combine them with the next
high frequencies, combine them with the
next high frequencies, combine them with
the next high frequencies, and so on.
And this is done by using what are
called upsampling blocks, U blocks, as
you can see here.
So this is this part here, again
convolution, non-linearity, and
upsampling. What do you do in
upsampling? You increase the resolution,
so you go from 32 squared to 32 squared
in a gradual manner, and you reduce the
number of channels. So as you can see
you are making something which is fat
and short into something which is thin
and tall. Okay, that's roughly the sort
of heuristics, yeah. So this is sort of
a very basic unit kind of an
architecture where we take
and all of these each of the ingredients
are in us, right? Because we are taking
non-linearities which are in all,
downsampling, upsampling, and the
convolutions, right? So this is this is
the basic structure.
But this is not enough because there are
some new features that you are also
adding.
And what you do is you use what are
called residual connections. Because
what are you doing is that you are
stacking a lot of layers. So when you
compute gradients you have to do
backpropagation, right? So you have to
do backpropagation when you compute
gradients. You If you lot of layers,
what happens is that the gradients could
explode or vanish. You have seen this in
some of the first lectures.
So, when you have so many layers, you
have to put in residual connections. And
these are done through these R blocks.
These These are here at the bottleneck.
These are also here at all the
intermediate frequencies, okay? So, what
is So, what is happening at this
bottleneck for instance? So, you take
the signal, you apply a convolution and
a non-linearity as before, but you keep
the signal. Okay? So, that means that uh
the gradient properties, there is
another another channel, another route
through which the gradient can come. So,
you don't have the smallness of the
gradients. So, this is roughly the
heuristic here. And it is done at all
levels, okay? Not just at the
bottleneck. Because in a traditional
U-Net, these parts are not there.
Okay? These are our sort of
fixes here because we want to keep a lot
of high-frequency content in the signal.
Otherwise, the high-frequency content
get gets lost. So, you have these
residual connections. And then, you have
them at every sort of intermediate
layer, okay? At every intermediate
layer, you have these kind of residual
connections.
Of course, all of them are in those, but
these are in order to ensure that this
multi-scale signal processing really
kicks in. That's why it's a very
elaborate architecture. Without that,
you won't get the sort of results that
you will see
in a in a moment. In addition, you also
have as in U-Nets, what are called
concatenations. So, what are these?
These concatenations is So, for
instance, let's focus here.
So, now you have applied this ResNet.
So, this is short and fat. And then, you
want to make it tall and thin. But you
have also kept some features from this
side here. So, from this frequency here,
and you just couple them together. Okay?
You couple them together, you
concatenate them, and you transform them
back. Same here. So, you have something
which is short and fat, you make it to
be tall and thin, and then you sort of
you have some features from here that
you're processing through ResNets and
you just concatenate them and then you
plug them up and you keep on doing this,
right? So, this is a very very elaborate
architecture in some sense because it
takes into account the fact that you
have information which is contained in
different frequencies. Okay? Yes.
Yeah.
Is what?
Yes, this is this is a it's a just by
how do you do
you did it also here, right?
So.
You No, no, you have these are learnable
mappings. So, what you take is a linear
layer which sort of increases the number
of channels uh it reduces the I think in
the tutorial they covered this if I'm
not mistaken. They must have covered it.
So, when you look at the code, all that
you do is that you have learnable
transformations which takes a 10 vector
and makes it into a 20 vector. You see
these are learnable linear
transformations. They don't do anything
with space. So, the this Reno properties
are only dependent on the spatial
information, right? These are just
adding channels. So, you can always do
that in a in a by using learnable These
are all learnable. So, these
architectures have lots of parameters
means uh you'll see in
in some of the examples that these have
lots of parameters. I think the biggest
models that we are running have like 400
million parameters. So, this this as you
can imagine these are these are not
cheap in that sense, right? They're not
cheap to train. They're not expensive to
infer. So, the key So,
I would say that these are details,
okay? These are details in order to get
sort of good performance. Even if you
don't have all of these ingredients, if
you just stack things together, you'd
still get something which is reasonable.
Okay? It's just that these things
increase the ability of this network, of
this operator of this uh
model to do this kind of multi-scale
information.
To do what is called multi-scale
information processing. Because that's
the name of the game that you have
multi-scale information processing, you
have information at different scales,
and you need to process them in a in a
neat manner. So, otherwise, all these
layers, all these blocks, and so on,
these are in some sense details.
You know, when you when you work in
machine learning, it's very very
important to have architectures that
have the best performance, uh that are
state-of-the-art, and then you need
these kind of additional features. But,
uh even the bare-bones version of it,
which will just be convolution on
linearities, convolution on linearities,
that that sort of works means it's not
uh
it's it does its job in some sense. Uh
but, now you have to remember that it
was the same with FNO. In FNO also,
there were these additional elements
that were there. You had some residual
connections somewhere, you had some MLP
somewhere. These are all there to add
information processing capacities. Okay?
Yes, James.
Yes, you can.
You can. This is the So, this is uh you
you can easily do that. We have done
that, and
yes, so that that that that functions.
That's You can You can do that.
It made it into a Reno, but it worsened
the performance.
Because what it did is that it clipped
off some features, you know? So, the
idea is that by making it things into a
Reno, you have to sort of take out some
frequencies, right? Means you have to
take out information. Otherwise, uh some
of the information is lost. So, all
these other ingredients, they bring back
this information. Okay? Somehow, you
have to keep the high-frequency content.
And by the way, I forgot before the
before uh the break, I forgot because uh
yeah, there are many things to say. But,
the whole point about maybe I said it uh
I didn't emphasize it. The whole point
of this activation layer is that now
it's non-local.
Right? Earlier, it was local. Means
because you were just applying a
function point-wise. Now, why is it
non-local? Because when you take a
function at a fixed number of points,
you increase the number of points
essentially by this uh upsampling
procedure, then it's local. But, then
again, it's non-local you're going back
to the function and coming back to the
So, this is a non-local is a genuine
operator. It's not just uh what is
called a Demitsky operator, which is the
application of a function operator on a
local function. So, this is uh somehow
the key trick in order to in order to
make this work. So, again, I emphasize
that these are details. This does not uh
it it affects a lot the performance,
actual deployment of these
architectures, but in principle, it does
not change the flavor. Okay, the flavor
is still contained in this basic
building blocks that I explained before
the break.
Good. So, I I proceed. Uh the Yes,
absolutely.
Yeah, you can the there are different
choices here, right? But, at the at the
end of the day, you have only a finite
amount of
um compute and a finite amount of mental
bandwidth to work with these things. So,
what it do what you do is is essentially
a binary processing. So, you start Your
images are always at resolutions which
are powers of two.
So, it makes a lot of sense to use
powers of two in this, right? So, so
let's say that you have an image which
is 1024 squared by 1024 squared. It's a
lot, right? Means, but what you do is
that in the first step, you reduce it to
512 squared by 512 squared, then 256 by
256, and so on. You could do it for any.
There is no in principle this
upsampling, downsampling need not be
done for probably just in the powers of
two. But you can imagine that you know
to have an optimal implementation,
caching and so on, it makes sense to
have things in powers of two. But
otherwise, you can always go from 100 to
80.
Uh you can always do that. But it's uh
not optimal, you know, in terms of how
you retrieve information from the cache,
how you store things, and so on. There's
also a implementational perspective to
it. And people who do computer vision,
for instance, they have to work with
images, you know, for instance, uh Sora
is working with 1920 by 1920, 2000 by
2000 images. They are doing this kind of
processing because they they need to.
They you cannot push in 2000 by 2000
images uh straight into a transformer.
So, they they they do this kind of
dimensionality reduction, information
compression
uh in an efficient manner because
otherwise, how will you means so
usually, powers of two are the trick.
Okay? So, you use the powers of two. But
there is no in principle, you can do
anything.
Further questions? No?
Okay. Let's have a quick look at what
are the properties of this um
construction. So, again, as long as your
polynomial or rational nonlinearities,
by construction, as I explained in the
before the break, by construction, you
get a reno.
Of course, uh if you don't have
polynomial nonlinearities or rational
nonlinearities, by construction, you you
you only get something approximation,
right? This is this is obvious.
What is also important here is that uh
there is a universal approximation
theorem. I did not focus so much on the
theory. Last last year I did, but this
year there's little time. So, what we
are going what what is the meaning of
this universal approximation theorem?
So, we have explained that in the
context of functions, right? So,
essentially for functions, as long as
the function is continuous, there was a
neural network which would approximate
it to the desired accuracy. You can do
the same for operators. Okay? So, now
you can think, "Okay, you have
continuous operators." So, this is of
course how do you define continuity?
It's
in the right kind of function spaces.
So, here we are using Sobolev spaces.
This is a detail. It's not important.
But essentially, let's say that your
operator is from X to Y.
And then a continuous operator would be
if you take
essentially roughly speaking
if you take G of
V minus G of V prime in Y
will be small
if
V minus V prime in X is small.
Right? So, this is roughly the mental
image. So, if the inputs are close to
each other in as functions, the outputs
are also close to each other as
appropriate functions. So, that would be
the definition of continuity. So, we go
a little bit further. Means you can do
that, but ideally you want what is
called a modulus of continuity. That's
why this there's this continuous plus,
which means roughly speaking
that this is not exact, but it is GV
minus GV bar in Y
behaves like little O of
V minus V bar in X.
Okay? So, you essentially if this guy
goes to zero, there is a modulus of
continuity. There is a rate at which
this guy goes to zero. That that's all.
If you have this property, then you can
prove that CNO, FNO, and DeepONet, all
of them are somehow universal
approximations. Those that satisfy this
property. This is
an analog of what happens to finite
dimensional vectors, right? So, a neural
network was approximating functions,
which are mappings between finite
dimensional spaces to arbitrary
accuracy. What we are showing here is
that a neural operator, CNO, FNO, and so
on, they can do the same for operators.
Okay? So, it is one level higher, but
the the principle is the same.
And anyway, the the idea of the proof, I
don't have time for this, but it's
essentially by
by saying that your operator is going to
be very well represented by mappings
between band-limited functions. Okay?
So, because there is this uh mappings
between band-limited functions, which
bands depend on the underlying function
spaces, and then you use the universal
approximation theorem for neural
networks and project it back. So,
essentially, that's that's the
that's that's the basic idea. And for
CNO, there is code. You have already
seen the code, and uh
you you are going to experiment with
that also for your forthcoming
exercises, right? So, this is uh the
thing with the theory as well as with uh
with practice. Let us see whether these
things work in practice or not. And I'll
show you some numerical experiments for
the rest of the lecture.
Okay, the first thing is uh we go back
to this very very simple problem that we
had before, but I'm going to do my
assignment. Uh this was just to show
that FNO, for instance, and CNN, these
were not reno's, right? So, you train at
a certain resolution, which was 61
squared,
and uh because the image was uh at 61
and then
Okay. And then you could see that as as
soon as of course here the Nyquist
barrier is broken, so nothing is going
to be a reno because there is no
one-to-one correspondence between the
discrete and the continuous. But here,
when the Nyquist conditions are
satisfied, you're taking a finer grid
than what the signal requires,
then what happens is that uh both CNN
and FNO, these were not reno's, right?
As soon as you change the grid even by
one grid point, the the errors were
amplified.
But SNO, as well as CNO, these are by
definition, they are constructed to be
they are constructed to be reno's, and
you can see that they were able to keep
it at machine precision. This uh this
aliasing error was zero to machine
precision. So, this was
completely expected because we have
constructed things in such a manner that
this property is going to be satisfied.
Okay, but let's look at some real
numerical results. Let's start with the
Navier-Stokes equations. So, all of you
should know what these equations are,
but if you don't, let me write it down
so because they come in again and again.
So, this is uh UT plus U.grad
U
plus gradient of P equal to zero. The
divergence of U is equal to zero.
And U is the velocity, so this is UX,
UY. These are the two components of the
velocity.
And P is the pressure, so this is the
This is the pressure, so a lot of fluid
dynamics is modeled by the Navier-Stokes
equations. And then we have the
vorticity.
Um because we are going to visualize
things in the vorticity quite a lot. So,
this is the curl of the velocity.
Curl of U. Okay? So, in 2D, this is a
scalar. In 3D, this is a vector.
But um perhaps I will have time to show
you some 3D results
at the end of the course, but let's
focus on the 2D. So, this is operator,
so it takes in I'm just showing one uh
component because otherwise
visualization becomes difficult. So,
this is some UX at time zero.
And then I am showing UX at time one.
Okay? So, this is my operator, so it
takes uh the two velocities and it turns
out the two velocities at a later time
at a fixed later time one.
And this is the vorticity, so this is
the vorticity at zero
and the vorticity at one. So, this tells
you what's happening, so you have some
shear layer
and because of the shear, the
vortices are generated. So, these are
the vortices that are generated. So,
this is a this is a nice problem. It's
sort of non-trivial, but at the same
time it's not ultra difficult, right?
So, now we apply different architectures
on it. So, we have CNO, FNO, we you saw
both of them.
By the way, this is not the correct
answer here.
Some reason I have got the wrong errors,
but
you'll see the correct errors at the at
the end. I made a mistake. Uh
and then we have UNet. So, what is UNet?
UNet is just
the same architecture, but without the
upsampling and the downsampling. Okay?
So, this is no longer a Reno. It's
exactly the same, but you kick out the
upsampling and the downsampling. Use a
straightforward convolution, and you use
a straightforward nonlinearity. So, this
is an ablation on on CNO.
It does not have this Reno property, but
it has every other feature. Okay? And
then there is also a fully connected
feed MLP. So, this is roughly a MLP.
Roughly. Of course, very expensive as a
consequence. And then we have DeepONet.
And you can see that just qualitatively
that first of all, DeepONet, we have
seen this before, it completely fails.
So, this CNN is nothing but the UNet.
Okay? So, this completely fails.
Just approximates the mean, and that's
the result why you get this kind of
large errors. It's not Also, in the last
lecture I tried to explain why that
could easily be the case because you
lose out all the spatial relationships
somewhat. Now, FNO does a good job. It
has 4% error, which is reasonable here.
What it does, unfortunately, is that
there are some artifacts, some aliasing
artifacts. For instance, this feature
here. The there is some artificial
features here, some ringing here. This
we believe is a sign of aliasing.
Uh UNet also has the same kind of
features. It has this aliasing again.
You can see here. You can see here, and
so on.
A CNO doesn't have these things, right?
It provides a good approximation, of
course, an approximation. It's not
exact. And this is done with the 1,000
samples. Okay, you need some training
samples. So, this is done with 1,000
samples.
And you can see that this this is a good
approximation. I think these numbers are
not exactly correct. You'll see the
correct numbers
I was probably making a mistake with
respect to the
But so this is this is what you see at a
fixed resolution. And this is 128 or 64
squared, I don't remember.
Now remember that what we really need to
do is to 64. Okay, because I see that
this that's the resolution. What happens
when you change resolution, right? So
when you change resolution as expected
with the U-Net uh
the errors really went up, right?
Because it's no longer a reno, you have
this aliasing effect. So it is not a
neural operator because we did not have
these ingredients in place.
FNO
somehow because it's partially a neural
operator in some sense because at least
the convolution does not add high
frequencies, only the nonlinearity does.
And here the the frequencies are not so
bad. So here this part
uh you have small errors, but they are
non-zero errors. This part you have lots
of errors, you know? So it really does
not is not able to understand when you
are at a lower grid resolution, what is
to be done. Even though the Nyquist
conditions are satisfied. Nyquist
conditions satisfied all the way up to
32.
So that's that's that's not an issue
here. Okay. CNO as expected, even though
we are using
um nonlinearity, I don't remember now, I
think it was Swish, which is not exact,
it retains the errors of no aliasing
errors up to more or less machine
precision here. Okay, so this is this is
as expected, it does its job. And you
can see that with the spectrograms. What
are the spectrograms?
I just take the output and I plot the
frequencies, okay? And this is in
logarithmic scale. As you can see, it
goes all the way from 10 to the power
minus three
to 10 to the power minus seven. And you
can see that um
between minus 32 and 32, a lot of
frequencies are represented. Most of the
frequencies are in this central region,
as you would expect, but there are some
frequencies outside. They're not not
completely zero, but they're decaying,
right?
Now, with CNO,
you approximate these frequencies. You
know, it's not exact. You approximate
these frequencies. You can see that
here, in particular, there are sort of
expected to be low frequencies, and you
have low frequencies.
Surprisingly, along these lines, there
are some higher than expected
frequencies, still within the band
limits. Otherwise, it wouldn't be a
reno, but for some reason, it tries to
expand along that direction. Who knows
why that happens. With FNO, on the other
hand, what it does is that it has very
large frequencies here.
So, these are very artificial
frequencies. Remember that this should
be 10 to the power minus seven. It is 10
to the power minus three. And as a
consequence, we believe that these
errors here, these errors here, and
these errors, these are from this kind
of a sort of expansion, wrong frequency
intake. And it's the same with the
U-Net. The U-Net has similar structure
to FNO, except that it has higher
frequencies in this region, right? So,
the darker the blue, the smaller the
values. Here, you can see that there are
larger values. So, of course, when you
change resolution, these high
frequencies, they seem to and they're
all over, right? So, these high
frequencies, they probably cause these
kind of large errors. So, this is
sort of some correlation between what
you have with the spectrogram, your
theoretical understanding, and what the
actual result are. So, this is the
situation with respect to
what happens when you when you think of
it as a neural operator, when you
evaluate the output at different grids.
Now, what's also very important is what
is called out of distribution
generalization. And let me explain this
concept at least a little.
So, what is out of distribution
generalization?
So, remember at the end of the day,
these
um samples, the training examples, and
the test examples,
they were drawn from some measure, mu,
which was a probability measure
on your band-limited functions, BW.
Because we are always working with
band-limited functions, so these were on
your band-limited functions, right? So,
this is how it looked like, your typical
sample. It looked like this. So, during
training, we generated 1,024 of these
samples. You trained or 768, I don't
remember. You trained your
architecture on it,
and you got some results. Okay, so this
was sort of the sort of the picture.
During testing, you took different
samples, which you have not seen during
training time, and you checked what the
what the errors were, and this was This
is the whatever you get, this 3.1, 3.93,
and so on. These were results on the
test set, right? But now, what you could
do is, what if I take a different
measure? So, all of them were drawn from
the same measure. Now, I take a
different measure, nu,
which is also a probability measure on
BW,
and I sample at inference my out I train
on this measure,
and I sample or I test on the on a new
measure. So, this is what is called out
of distribution, right? Because now, the
data that you're giving is different
from the data that you generated. Oh,
how does it
How does it mean? As you can see here,
so this was some initial layer, and we
had some perturbations on that initial
layer, and so on. Now, what we do is
that we have bigger perturbations, which
are not seen during training time, and
we also change the location of the
layer. So, we move it, okay? So, this
has also not been seen by the data
during training time.
As you can see, the output changes,
means
this is an example, the output was here,
the ground truth, and the ground truth
here is a bit different. And the
question is, can it sort of extrapolate?
Okay, this is always a challenge with
neural networks. It has never seen this
training distribution, but this training
distribution is not completely off,
right? It is still uh relatively close
to each other. In other words, if you
take a distance, uh you can't have a
distance, but you can have you can't
have a norm, but you can have a distance
between measures.
These are close to each other. Uh I
think this I don't remember. It depends
on what metric that you take, but these
are within
let's say 50% of each other. Roughly
speaking, and so they're not they're not
completely far. So, how do these uh
methods perform?
So, it turns out that the the results
that you get are very, very interesting.
So, let's focus, for instance, on CNO
and FNO. So, now you can see that What
does CNO do? It sort of provides a right
resolution to these features.
Right? It provides a right resolution to
these features. Here, on the other hand,
it introduces something that was not
there before.
But at least it understands that there
is some distinction in here, there is
some distinction here, and so on.
What does FNO do? It does not resolve
this feature nicely. It puts it at a
different place.
And not only that, uh it puts something
here, which was not there in the ground
truth. And also here, remember that
there is a connection between these two
vertices. It simply uh it does not even
have them here. Right? So,
qualitatively, you can see the
difference. And the same with the U-Net.
Means, even though the U-Net and uh CNO
are very similar to each other, you just
have this additional upsampling,
downsampling. You see that U-Net has
completely missed this entire feature
here. It has just put it here. Okay? And
also, it has put these things here. So,
now when you look at the predictions,
you can see that, of course, all of them
make bigger errors. I mean, this is the
the the they're not going to do This is
sometimes also called zero-shot. Okay?
You are not You're not having any access
to the test to the to to new measure.
You just do it in a zero-shot manner,
and you can see that the at least in
this particular case, CNO had slightly
better generalization. The error was
only doubled, which is roughly along
expected lines, because the measure was
the distance was like 50%. So, you'd
expect that the error would be doubled.
But here, for instance, FNO the error
was increased by roughly a factor of
three, right? And uh unit also it was
increased roughly by a factor of three.
DeepONet was anyway doing very poorly in
the in the previous regime, and it kept
on doing poorly in this regime. So, this
is sort of an important test case for
any machine learning architecture. That
how well does it do
in terms of extrapolation? When we
change the measure, how well uh can it
do? And this is also telling you
something about the nature of the data
and the nature of the model. So, if you
fix the data, like we did in this
particular case, it is something about
the model. So, do we gain anything? Of
course, we do gain, because we have a
code in my lab, which is very, very
fast.
So, for instance, on a 100 squared grid,
it takes 1/10 of a second to solve this
problem. So, it's it's very, very fast.
But uh with CNO or FNO, for that matter,
it takes a thousand times less. So,
there is some error, but you get uh
results in
thousand times less time, right? So,
this is the whole point of machine
learning. And you'll see later on that
these numbers are going to be even
bigger later on. Okay? But is this
concept of out-of-distribution clear?
That you really changed the test
distribution from the training
distribution. And we will see some more
extreme examples of it uh
in the in the coming lectures.
Okay, so this was I have many, many
examples, and I certainly don't have the
time to go through all of them.
Uh okay, this is also an important
point. Uh it says success is a
histogram, not a point, because this was
uh essentially Now, we have uh I don't
remember the test set is 256 or 512
samples. The numbers that were reported
were like median over this median errors
over this set. So of course there is a
bigger spread.
And if you look at the histogram both in
distribution and out of distribution you
can see that in distribution it's clear
that FNO sorry CNO does better than FNO
and UNET.
But in out of distribution is where it
does really better, right? Because you
can see that almost all the errors are
between anywhere between 3 and 8% or 3
and 10% whereas if you take FNO it
starts around 9% and it goes all the way
up to 20%, right? So it has a better
spread in terms of extreme events.
Even the extremes are not so bad.
Whereas with FNO I think in this
particular case but this could be this
could be due to aliasing. That's one we
saw some artifacts due to that or it
could be due to some intrinsic nature of
the model and the data. It's sometimes
it's very difficult to say that.
Okay, let me go through some other
examples so that
okay this is this is not important.
Because I I have to make a choice now.
So here is another example which is a
very simple one but turns out to be
difficult for machine learning.
So this is a Poisson equation. So you
have minus Laplacian of U equal to F
on some domain so 0 1 squared.
And U on the boundaries is I think zero
if I remember correctly and then the
operator just takes the forcing
and turns out to U. Okay? And the
forcing is taken from some measure so
the F is distributed according to a
random field Gaussian random field.
Or maybe it's not a Gaussian random
field. It's some signs I think. It
doesn't look like a Gaussian random
field.
Um
let's see. Some
some of signs.
So as you can see this is my input. You
can see that it's a sum of so I've taken
20 or 30 signs. And then of course, what
the Poisson equation does is that it's
diffusion, so these modes are diffused
out.
The solution is still fairly
complicated, and these are the
predictions. So, you have U-Net, CNO.
U-Net and CNO are the same in this
particular case, means as as you would
expect. Strength of CNO is what happens
when you go to a different grid. FNO
does very very poorly in this particular
example, means we still don't understand
why, but it does as you can see many
many new features are introduced and it
doesn't it doesn't do a good job at all.
And you can see that when you do an out
of distribution, out of distribution is
you add more signs. So, I think we took
20 signs for the in distribution set
up to 20 signs, and here it's 30 signs.
So, you can see that the signal is much
more, let's say, wavy in some sense.
And again, CNO does an excellent job and
FNO completely fails, right? It's sort
of it does very poorly. And this is also
reflected in the in the in the results
here. So, this is like 0.2% it's almost
no error, and this one is like 20 30
times more. So, a lot lot lot lot more
error in this particular case.
And if you do the same kind of analysis
as before
again, U-Net as expected it does very
very poorly. The
as you change the resolution, it's not a
Reno so the errors go up in this U-shape
manner.
Uh, same with FNO, actually in this
particular case it did poorly so there
are there are large errors on both
directions. CNO of course does very well
here where the Nyquist barrier is
satisfied.
When the Nyquist barrier is not
satisfied, because remember that it's
it's just an approximation it there was
there were some small errors, right? And
you see that beautifully in the
spectrogram.
So, here is the spectrogram for the
ground truth. For CNO it's almost an
exact match. FNO has all these high
frequencies where they shouldn't be, as
does U-Net. Right? So, they really it
shows this problem shows that aliasing
is a real concern. If you have aliasing,
then then you end up with the these kind
of
with these kind of artifacts. Right? And
then I have many many examples. I don't
want to give all of them because there
is no time. Maybe I focus on a couple.
So, this is a very very simple problem,
transport equation, okay? And what does
transport equation do?
So, transport equation is essentially UT
plus um
c.grad u equal to zero. In 2D, so all
the all the tests are in 2D. c.grad u
equal to zero. c is a vector now, c1,
c2.
And then your solution u of uh
x, y, t
is equal to u0 of x minus c1t, y minus
c2 of
So, a very very simple problem. Of
course, a machine learning algorithm
doesn't know that this is a simple
problem. It just has data and it is
going to see the things with respect to
data.
So, now we take a very simple uh for the
in distribution, we take essentially a
Gaussian bump, okay? We take a Gaussian
bump which is given here. And then we
transport it, right? So, we transport it
with a velocity field which will take it
in this direction. So, the output is
like this. And uh for the initial
distribution, what we do is that we
change the strength of the bump, we
change the size of the bump, and so on.
The location is always around these
these points, okay?
And you can see CNO gets almost a
perfect answer, FNO also gets a perfect
answer as does U-Net. Nothing nothing
changes. And if you look at the numbers,
they are like 0.3%, 0.4%,
1.4% and so on. I mean, all of them are
good, right? But now, the challenge here
is out of distribution. So, out of
distribution, what happens is So, during
the training, it always sees the initial
location of the bump in this corner, in
the bottom left. Now, what I do is that
I keep the same sort of problem, but I
simply translate the bump to the top
right. Okay? And when I translate the
bump to the top right,
of course, this is just
advection, so it will just go there. All
that is happening is essentially a
translation, right? And remember that
convolutions are translation invariant.
Okay, that's the whole point. So, of
course, CNO does a very, very good job.
Not exact, but almost almost as before.
U-Net 2, almost as before. There is some
aliasing, that's why the error is large.
We believe larger. FNO is not
translation invariant. Why is that? Can
anyone tell me why?
Hey, James.
Yes. So, this is once you go to Fourier,
you'll destroy the locality, and then,
you no longer have
translation invariance, and you see
that. So, it does some translation, it's
but at the same time, it thinks that
there is some feature which is still
left behind. Right? So, here, you
out of distribution performance is not
good. It's like So, translation
invariance it's good to have, because in
a lot of physics, you have translation
invariance, right? And what is left is
the very, very poor performance, for
instance, of these guys, of MLP, and of
DeepONet. I mean, these are like
insanely bad. And this is not because we
made a mistake, they just don't
understand. I mean, there is no notion
of space here whatsoever. And so,
translation is not even understood here,
because it's a spatial operation, right?
So, you see here
that it just keeps
it remembers that there was something
here, and now it is given something
here, so it just interpolates between
them, right? It completely fails. And
DeepONet,
Um,
it does not understand the shape at all,
but it does some translation, but it
keeps a very, very large feature here
for some reason. So, sometimes,
you know, the theory and practice are
not completely uncorrelated from each
other. You understand the theory and you
expect certain things and that is what
is born out in practice. So, this was a
good test for out of distribution
performance of our neural architecture
and you see see the results here.
The last example that I'll give are what
I call the compressible Euler equations.
Means we have seen these equations
before, so I'm not going to rewrite
them.
And again, this is this flow past the
airfoil, right? So, our familiar problem
that we have dealt with many, many
times.
So, now the difference is what is in the
definition of the operator. Okay? So,
earlier you have seen that operator was
from the initial data to the final time.
It was from the forcing term to the
final time and so on. And now you can
see that this is slightly different
operator because operator, roughly
speaking, is a mapping from the shape
to the flow.
Okay? So, that is the definition. And
what is the shape here? The shape is
defined in terms of the shape of the
airfoil, which is given as a mask.
Okay? So, it gives you zero values here
and some non-zero or one values here and
zero values here. It's like a mask. That
is the input and you you check it from a
in-distribution and out-of-distribution.
Out-of-distribution, you simply have
more basis functions. Remember that we
had this Hicks-Henney functions.
Uh, if you recall from some of the
previous lectures. So, I think here we
take 20 and here we take 32 or 16 and
32. Uh, the numbers could be wrong.
Uh, the
they do a good job. The the machine
learning architecture, CNO for instance,
um,
where is it? Here.
This is in-distribution and this is
out-of-distribution. Does Does a Does a
good job. In-distribution, very, very
accurate. Out-of-distribution, fairly
accurate, but not not completely. As you
can see that the shock is right here. It
has moved a bit. It has diffused it out
a bit, but it's just just a bit. That's
why you get 0.62.
FNO, for instance, um does also a good
job, but it has these artifacts.
You see here and here.
Again, this is a sign of, we believe, of
aliasing. Okay? Uh U-Net, similar, but
U-Net does not alias as much in this
particular case, right? It has has
perhaps more diffusion for some reason.
And why did I show this? Uh first of
all, the performance is very good. The
point here is, you know, to generate any
of these results with a traditional
numerical method, even with a very
optimized code, this will take me 100
seconds. Okay? Because this is a harder
problem, this will take me 100 seconds.
CNO, FNO, any of these, it takes, again,
as before, right? The inference time is
1/10,000 of a second. Okay? So, once you
have a trained neural network, you can
do things even in 2D, six orders of
magnitude faster. So, if you wanted to
do design, airfoil design, as before,
and you needed 1,000 iterations, this
would take me 1,000 * 100 seconds, which
is a lot of time. This will take me 1
second.
So, this is uh less than 1 second. It
takes time to, of course, set things up.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah,
this is because, you know, the set of
shapes is uh you can't go completely
crazy with shapes. For instance, if I
would have taken 50 of these hexanate
functions, I'll get shapes that are not
feasible anyway. So, even the
even the flow itself does not make any
sense around them. So, in the regime
that we have for this particular
airfoil,
uh it will work in every case.
Okay? What is interesting is what
happens if you change the inflow
conditions, because the inflow
conditions here can be very very
different, the angle of attack and so on
and so forth. I think with our
preliminary test it it might because you
can't change the angle of attack from 1°
to 5° then your plane will certainly
crash. Okay, so you don't want to
simulate that or 10° so within the bands
because engineering is a long narrow
bands, you see then it sort of
extrapolates quite well. But that
doesn't mean that if I change the shape
entirely it will do a good job, you know
moments I have to change a different
parameterization all together.
That that may not do may not do such a
good job. So these these these methods
have their limits huh? They are not
without limits. You'll see the limits
very soon.
Okay, so this was actually the sort of
results. I somehow made a mistake
because the number was not um
3.1 it was 2.76 and 3.57 but roughly it
is you can see that there are different
examples and it's always similar story.
The strength of CNO is in the fact that
it has this three no property, right? So
you don't have aliasing errors and so
on.
And the last point which I want to talk
about is a little bit about
computational efficiency.
Not in terms of inference because
inference is always very fast. What
about training?
So training is epochs, right? You have
to run for different kinds of epochs.
So in this particular case
I think
um
roughly speaking we just compare with
FNO where FNO is the most sort of um
good baseline in some sense and you see
that in terms of time per epoch, model
size also but in terms of time
it consistently was better performing
than FNO. In particular, if you take
here is the sort of the bottom line it's
around 4.2 seconds and with less error
you could train
uh
in 3 seconds. So, you know, the training
time is comparable actually. It's It's a
bit faster even, right? So, in other
words, per epoch it takes about 3
seconds.
So, if you take 300 epochs, it will take
900 seconds to train. Okay, so this is
roughly the the constraint. Of course,
these are relatively small models. I
think these are like 3 million. Perhaps
the FNO was 7 million in this particular
case and CNO was like 3 million. So,
these are not big models. They're still
much bigger than what we saw before,
which was like 10,000 parameters, right?
Remember I had these examples with the
10,000 parameters. But the biggest
models that we have are like 400 million
parameters and these takes a week to
train. So, of course, the bigger There
is some scaling issue. But we're going
to address the scaling issue
next week. Okay, so with this
it seems like everything works, but
you'll see that that's not the case.
There are several issues that we are
going to deal with on Friday. Okay, so
let's meet again on Friday and then we
can we can take it from there.